bad dad or unreliable narrator
mistreating Missy or sheer child neglect
young Sheldon isn't the childlike fairy
tale you think it is and for a lot of
fans the controversy just steers the pot
for a big bang in the making
most fans can forgive young Sheldon's
producers for casting actor Lance Barber
as the character George Cooper senior
after he played Leonard's bully Jimmy
speckerman in season five of The Big
Bang Theory but usually they still can't
get over the bad dad narrative
perpetuated in the original show my
father used to say that a woman is like
an egg salad sandwich on a warm Texas
day during its early Seasons young
Sheldon established George Cooper as a
caring and thoughtful father and husband
sure he doesn't always get it right and
is tough on the kids sometimes but it's
a far cry from the skeet obsessed
redneck described on The Big Bang Theory
Barber's performance has prompted many
fans online to debate if and when we'll
see the real George Cooper emerge with
one Reddit user claiming that has been
one thing that has irked me to no end
George Cooper senior's character is such
a well-written one most of the scenes
with him are my favorites from the show
another fan suggested that young Sheldon
viewers are seeing the true version of
George speculating that Sheldon on the
Big Bang Theory is just an unreliable
narrator he often recalls events from
his childhood without having all the
facts and even over-exaggerates aspects
of other characters
some young Sheldon fans take issue with
how Reagan rewards character Missy is
treated or rather mistreated by her
family one Reddit fan commented I don't
like that their parents and Mima heard
Missy say she doesn't have anyone on her
team and yet they still didn't make more
of an effort with her this moment takes
place in episode 5 of season 2 while
Sheldon and Missy are being evaluated in
a twin study Missy who's observed by Dr
Thorpe is being very perceptive says her
perception comes from being on her own a
lot she explains that her mom dad and
Mima are often busy tending to Georgie
or Sheldon so she has no one supporting
her shocked by this realization they do
initially start to make more of an
effort to be there for her first by
letting her pick the restaurant on the
way home however the Cooper's neglectiv
Missy largely continues giving rewards
some big scenes in season six as another
Reddit user pointed out her family just
continues to prove that they aren't
really on her team leaving Missy to feel
like the Forgotten member of the family
this is especially true when she misses
the birth of her knee and in The
Following episode she runs away from
home
when the series kicks off Sheldon's
maternal grandmother Connie Tucker
nicknamed Mima hasn't moved on from the
death of her husband four years earlier
as season one continues she starts to
form a connection with Sheldon's
professor and friend John Sturgis by the
season finale they've made their
relationship official with Sheldon's
first ever relationship contract please
sign and date
you know Sheldon I'm a notary if that
helps just when I thought you couldn't
get cooler young Sheldon fans were
thrilled to see this relationship
Blossom with a user on Reddit commenting
John and Connie are so full of love and
understanding kudos to the makers for
hitting the sweetest spot on the show
another user agreed commenting can we
please have John and Connie forever they
are so adorable together however John
and Connie's relationship only lasted
one season with them splitting after
John's mental breakdown at the end of
season 2. he even though Connie has
since dated Dale Ballard played by Craig
T Nelson young Sheldon fans are still
seemingly unable to get over her split
with Jon with many still hoping they'll
get back together
Emily Osmond's character Mandy
McAllister has been part of young
Sheldon since she met Georgie Midway
through season five their relationship
quickly developed and by the time the
season was out Mandy was pregnant
however before they discovered they're
going to be parents their romance
abruptly ended when Georgie admitted he
wasn't 21 years old but actually 17.
early in season six Georgie tries to get
back into Mandy's good graces doing
everything he can to make her pregnancy
more comfortable they continue to learn
about one another often acting like any
dating couple but when Mandy and Georgie
bring the newborn Constance Cooper
nicknamed CeCe home from the hospital
they're still not a functioning couple
no matter how devoted they are to their
child although Osmond is a welcome
addition to the cast many fans want the
show to move on from this situationship
with one Reddit user commenting this
whole thing with Mandy and Georgie is
quite ridiculous can they just have them
officially together already not all fans
are rooting for the pair with some
suggesting that Georgie would be better
off without Mandy but either way it's
seems as if things are finally moving in
some direction initiated by Georgie's
surprise proposal late in season six
when viewers first meet McKenna Grace's
page in season two she's a sweet gifted
child who eventually takes a dark turn
after her parents Divorce by season 3
it's clear this child prodigy is
struggling everything that used to seem
important to me
just
doesn't anymore by season 6 Paige has
taken on a new title of the underage
party girl as a Reddit user pointed out
each guest appearance has shown her
progressively getting worse Paige once
admitted to Sheldon that she wasn't
being taken seriously as a young woman
in science and ultimately dropped out of
college Paige loses her way and winds it
back at East Texas Tech with one
redditor observing now she's just going
off with a nasty attitude and then
getting drunk at parties some young
Sheldon fans were completely shocked by
this suggesting that her actions are an
obvious cry for help with one user
commenting the show won't go that deep
but I wonder if she lived to see her 20s
it looks like her teenage years are
going to be dark
the world isn't always fair and young
Sheldon proves it in season five when
Mary is fired from her job at the church
Matt Hobbies Pastor Jeff brings Mary
George and Pastor Rob played by Dan bird
into his office after the congregation
learns that Georgie is having a baby out
of wedlock he beats around the bush
before telling Mary that she needs to
leave although she quickly finds a job
working at the bowling alley audiences
criticized Pastor Jeff for firing her
one Reddit user commented I feel like
Jeff is a hypocrite being divorced is
enough to disqualify him even being a
Baptist pastor one would think he'd be
more sympathetic other fans agreed that
while wrong Pastor Jeff was pressured
into it to save face with the other
members of the church but this storyline
is probably not over yet when we see
Mary in The Big Bang Theory she's still
involved with the church so maybe Pastor
Jeff will make things right
of course many of the biggest storylines
in young Sheldon are dictated by The Big
Bang Theory one that looms over the
whole series is the death of George
which is supposed to occur when Sheldon
and Missy are 14 years old with George
having two heart attacks in the first
five seasons young Sheldon has been
setting the tone for this storyline for
a long time
six the twins are nearing that age and
some fans are bracing for impact with a
Twitter user commenting it occurs to me
that the show has to have George die
before the end and I don't think I'm
emotionally ready for that other fans
are hoping to avoid the Heartbreak
convinced by the differences in George's
character between young Sheldon and the
Big Bang Theory that his death won't
happen however writer and executive
producer Steve Holland told TV line that
the show would be largely sticking to
the canonical events laid out in The Big
Bang Theory
some young children fans have always
been critical of our protagonist
favoring other characters and storylines
but now in season 6 some think he's
become completely irrelevant while a
young genius furthers his education at
East Texas Tech and works on his
database project some viewers suspect
that there is no more room for Sheldon's
development a Twitter user commented the
worst least likable and uninteresting
character on young Sheldon is Sheldon
and it's not the actor's fault Ian's
Sheldon cannot grow beyond the point at
which we first saw the character in Big
Bang Theory in a Reddit thread
discussing Sheldon's lack of a solid
storyline one user said now it feels
forced and weird the other characters
have story lines that grow and move
along Sheldon's academics have just
become boring another user agreed adding
they're seriously going to have to
figure out where they want to take his
character by the end of the seventh
season
George and Mary don't have the perfect
marriage but their hearts usually are in
the right places however there are some
things that Mary can't always get from
George like deep conversation as a
result she's grown closer to Pastor Rob
her close friend Confidant and smoking
buddy what's going on here uh Brian
we're Brian just praying while it's
pretty clear that the youth pastor wants
more than a platonic friendship and
Mary's been fantasizing about being
together with him nothing has actually
happened between the pair and some fans
are angry over how seemingly ridiculous
the storyline is with one Twitter user
commenting the young Sheldon plot with
Mary being accused of cheating with
Pastor Rob deal with being thrown out of
her church and maybe have one friend
makes me want to put my TV through a
wall other fans on Reddit claim that
they couldn't see Mary cheating on
George believing that the show is
unnecessarily building up her possible
fling with Rob only for a dramatic
effect
Sheldon explains in The Big Bang Theory
that he once walked in on his father
with another woman but some young
Sheldon fans can't seem to get over the
storyline in which George cheats this is
since it doesn't fit with the character
they've gotten to know one viewer
commented the Mary and George parts are
disappointing I hated that their
marriage is bad that they are looking at
others sad I liked it much better when
they loved only each other some
audiences think George's budding affair
with Brenda Sparks played by Melissa
Peterman is just an attempt to stay
faithful to The Big Bang Theory one
viewer said no reason to ruin a good
show trying to be faithful to another
show that's off the air how far George
has taken this budding affair with
Brenda is unclear but while they're at
the hospital in episode 14 of season 6
they exchange banter which seems to
suggest some form of intimacy I did not
give me something well
in the episode a launch party and a
whole human being moments after that
hospital scene between George and Brenda
Mary enters with Pastor Robin toe I hear
we're having a baby
what did I miss it however nobody is
particularly focused on the laboring
mother at that moment instead with Mary
catching on to George's Brenda's mystery
man and George thinking that Mary and
Pastor Rob were doing more than just
grabbing lunch for hours their
relationship reaches a Breaking Point
speaking to TV line executive producer
Steve Holland explained why this was the
perfect time for this to come to a head
we didn't want to do the traditional
you're in the delivery room and she's
panting episode it just seemed like a
great way to have these stories all
crash together some viewers think the
cheating story lines are a bit
ridiculous and agree that the birth of
their granddaughter is neither the time
nor the place to get into them one
Twitter user commented Mandy's mom is
the worst but she has a point Mandy is
in labor but the only real family she
has at the moment would rather fight
over their crushes than check on her if
Georgie's situation with Mandy is
anything to go by it's clear he's
willing to lie to get a girl in season 2
Georgie meets and starts dating Veronica
played by Isabel may but after an
intense makeout session Veronica decides
to change gears and devote her life to
Christianity so in order to keep dating
Veronica Georgie pretends that he's also
devout Georgie if you want to be a good
Christian maybe you should stop lying
through your teeth just be happy I
brushed him okay but their relationship
ends shortly after with Veronica last
seen across a restaurant when Georgie's
on a date with his new girlfriend
although she only appeared for a handful
of episodes in the first three seasons
of young Sheldon fans enjoyed Veronica's
transformation into a responsible young
woman and were disappointed in her
abrupt departure on Reddit a user posted
is anyone else annoyed at the removal of
Veronica she was one of my favorite
characters and I loved her relationship
with everyone on the show several other
fans agreed noting that Veronica's
storyline never came to a satisfying
conclusion others are hoping that she'll
return and reunite with Georgie with a
viewer comment Veronica seemed like a
sweetheart and I think she'd have been a
better fit for Georgie instead of Mandy
[Music]